bethany it's so wonderful to chat with
you because uh we want to take a moment
to commend you and your team at be
strong for everything you're doing
especially what's going on in the world
i mean when you heard about russia and
ukraine uh what was your initial
thoughts
first of all i wanted to understand it
more a lot of my information i hear from
my social media following to be honest
with you that's been going on
historically for several years since be
strong started when people get really
passionate about something whether it's
telling me that we're running out of
masks or uh the jones act in puerto rico
so first of all i wanted to get educated
on what it was and we were immediately
on the ground figure out what the needs
were and the needs have have shifted
they have layered and added it began
with there's a massive crisis and this
will be a humanitarian crisis with a
mass exodus
imminent and that meant
what will people need when they cross
what will the logistics be for where
they want to go this is plane tickets
this is train tickets then people
decided they wanted to stay in poland so
that was interesting uh figuring out
local travel and airbnb type travel and
then wanting to distribute aid uh
distribute aid back into ukraine was in
the next development realizing that
there was limited food supply and
medical supplies so now we have to
figure out our infrastructure to move
aid back
and that turned into
multiple european brands who can donate
so we obviously it's more expensive to
ship things from the united states so to
get european brands to donate and then
use that for the aid use our local
warehouses to house aid and trucks for
logistics to get the aid back in and now
the latest request has been for uh
civilians asking for helmets
wow so you jumped into gear because of
what you saw on social media you saw the
news and you knew you had to do
something uh do you know anybody in the
ukraine do you have any friends or
family there
no i don't know anybody i've been to
russia i was in russia when i was in
high school when i was uh 14 years old
um and it was
very then that was a scary time there um
so no i mean but i i don't know anybody
in puerto rico either or any you know it
just we just do what's important they're
all everyone it's just people it's not
politics if we're not political we just
see people suffering and people being
separated from their families and kids
crying because they don't know why their
dad's been taken away i mean just crazy
crazy stories from every angle and so
you have to figure out what's going on
there that's why we've seen that many of
the orgs
they have one model
so that model may not fit what's going
on and we've seen that every single time
it's something different so you have to
be
sort of like a
a contractor that's going to say okay in
this case people need ppe in this case
we need helmets and lastly another time
it was hazmat suits people's needs
change every time and we've never seen
the same needs twice that's what's
really crazy isn't it crazy bethany too
i mean you're a parent i'm a parent and
when you watch these videos like you
said about a father and kids being
separated i mean this is where you
really want to push to even
help even more have you heard stories i
mean you're you know you're with people
on the ground have you heard stories
that we're not seeing in the news
um
i've heard a lot of
family separation stories i've heard
stories
of
people not knowing when they're going to
see their husbands again like there's
just some people say wanting to stay in
poland nearby because they're in limbo
they're sort of in purgatory they don't
know
they're paralyzed think about that and
you have to really
picture what it would be like to have
nothing
yesterday your life was one thing today
it's totally different and then there's
just there are superficial aspects how
dirty you feel how exhausted you feel
how high dehydrated you are just think
about what it would be like if you just
had to go out and just stand anywhere
and still for 24 hours much less be on a
train and be exhausted and hungry and
not understand which direction is up i
think there's just like a physical
taxing that also people aren't allowed
to even have because they've got to keep
moving so there's so much going on and
fear
thank
and hearing explosions in a different
reality for your kids i mean it's just
it's endless the trauma
yeah and and you and be strong have
raised 3.5 million dollars your aim is
to get to 5 million
we're close to five it's hard to it's
hard to i keep reading headlines and
saying ah you know because that was that
that was this morning that this morning
and tonight is is a million dollar
difference
incredible congratulations on that how
are the funds being distributed
the funds will be distributed i approved
a hundred thousand dollars for example
today for i approve the money i i have
to approve every uh expenditure so the
hundred thousand dollars today is for
protective helmets the seven hundred
fifty thousand dollars for yesterday is
for food and medical going into ukraine
uh there there are endless it's like
well how do you fee
what are you spending the money on in a
house meaning i have plumbing i have
heating i have so the aid though the the
physical aid that we talk about the goya
foods the crisis boxes those are donate
that those are all donated our warehouse
that has 60 million dollars in aid in
miami that's been donated from people
like delta and kind and endless brands
that donate to us we're very lucky now
we used to not use that to beg for aid
the money is spent for something
specific
to this need it could be travel and
plane tickets a lot of travel for
refugees relocating so it varies
yeah and you've actually got connected
with global empowerment mission which
you're talking about those flights i
mean how has that been working with
getting people out into their families
people from ukraine
so a global empowerment mission is my
501c3 logistics
partner
um and getting people out is satisfying
because it requires
organization and travel partners and
communication but keeping people right
there is not a good idea because of
these camps that are really over like
going to overload the system in europe
in poland it's much so you have to kind
of get people
going and and people are looking for
airbnb like solutions i mean so many
people have emailed to offer homes and
situations like that but it requires
planning you can't just show up and
knock on someone's door and take you
know down so it there's a lot going on
there are a lot of moving parts and it
will be several months long after the
headlines fade i mean you know i know
it's fashion week and i know it's sag
awards and i don't know
food
festivals but this is a real real thing
so
and you have tents set up as well
explain to me what happens in those
tents
the tents are basically initially we
just thought we would be giving out uh
crisis kids but not everybody needs a
whole survival kit of a blanket and
and um a charger some people want some
water and a snack other people want uh
tampons or diapers other people want to
talk about travel so you have to meet
their various needs we planned for pets
but it has not been a need there's we've
seen two pets only so you know people
want to be heard and want you to talk to
them and and they just want to feel
supported which is a big part of it too
so it's a mixed bag but it's just
constant constant endless buses
endless buses
and have you talked to people who are on
the grounds helping the people of
ukraine have you
felt their emotions of being there
say it's very very sad it's different
it's it's
a different way um you know when you're
in a place like puerto rico after
maria and people lost their homes in one
second just
they're filled with water and they're
just gone and they've lost everything
that's a different sort of emotion than
this which is like am i seeing my
husband again am i not are we moving
forever is it going on is it going off
like it sort of feels like your mind's
playing tricks on you it seems so it's a
different
way of dealing with people and talking
to them you're sort of counseling them
and just trying to help like an
information post
what has been the biggest challenge for
you i mean we were talking about you're
trying to help people there's a martial
law in place where males can't leave the
country like what has been the biggest
challenge for you and be strong to be
able to get to the people
getting to getting back into ukraine is
its own logistical aspect right you know
you also don't want to be a target and
you know i don't want to say a ton about
that but you're going back into
a war-torn country so that's got its own
level of uh
challenges and it needs to be taken
seriously um
lack of service on the border not be
hard to be hard to communicate and get
things done in that regard um just being
exhausted and um trying to
stay cool calm and collected and uh
always be organized and and you have to
be nimble you have to move with
the changes the needs that change
every minute so that's something is
great about
be strong is the transparency that's one
of these people have loved they want to
hear what's going on and one of the
other challenges is always
people making it political
yeah arguing about blame and then making
it political but also having to
deal with anybody involved many people
involved in crisis relief
want to
get credit or
politic different political parties
care who you take money from like it get
there just logistics like that where
you're trying to keep everybody happy
because we just want to raise more money
so we're not making this political we
just want to raise money to help people
and it's amazing how much money you're
raising the fact that you had 10 million
for a distribution now you've doubled it
to 20 million i understand
the aid distribution i don't have an
updated number past 10 million but we're
certainly
well over 15 million yeah now in
surpassing our goal i mean this is the
this is this is the most remarkable
generosity
of a nation that i've ever seen yeah
how do you do it like how do you make
this all happen i mean there's people
who want to help but you are actually
doing it
practice makes perfect i mean i just the
first time was hurricane harvey and i
could not like i always tell the same
story it was hurricane harvey and i was
calling a mattress company and calling a
rainbow company i couldn't get any rain
boots and mattresses i raised over three
hundred thousand dollars in money and in
kind and went to texas led by example
people seeing me there made them feel
safer made them realize i was walking
the walk and then going on to maria and
thinking that was the greatest relief
effort we had ever done because it was
millions and millions of pounds of aid
and 53 planes both ways and then the
bahamas was
i think we raised a million dollars in
the donations not including the aid this
is remarkable but it's practical i mean
it's keep doing it keep learning and be
a good communicator be transparent and
involve the people which is what they
really really want to be part of
something and they want to feel like
we're getting it done it's i'm tired i'm
getting i'm getting tired you're getting
there
and how can people help how can they get
involved with you and be strong uh
bethany.com b-e-t-h-e-n-n-y
dot com slash be strong
i love 100 goes to the effort
no you're pretty hands-on are do you
have any plans of going to europe i
actually wanted to go this week and my
partner said
you won't have how are we going to get
all this done if you're here then you
won't have service and he said it takes
20 hours two plane flights an hour and a
half to get to and from the site but you
will have service twice a day so i
thought how am i there's so you can't
imagine the number of requests i'm
getting a day for just every single
thing and i don't want to miss anything
because
you know one thing could be a massive
donation from a european food company i
got a massive multiple hundred thousand
pieces clothing donation yesterday so
you're kind of trying to balance it all
it's not that easy
and
you know the fact they've done so much
and here we are in 2022 talking about a
war
what are your thoughts on it
uh
you know what my real thoughts that came
to mind just now is social media can be
used for good not evil i've proven that
with this these efforts but
social media is holding
this war accountable
where years ago so many things happen
that people couldn't see you know people
brutality and killings that people
couldn't see so social media
is really making it that everybody's
eyes are watching so if you're seeing
people behave differently you're seeing
soldiers behave differently than maybe
they would if nobody was watching that's
what's really
fascinating about it um
and
maybe that means
the world will eventually become a
better place for that reason i mean
social media can be
vile in so many ways but in that regard
that's interesting at least to talk
about
and also for kids to be looking at
people fighting for their country
fighting for what they is their own and
pride and patriotism i think that's
interesting also
yeah thank you so much for everything
you're doing and chatting with us and
you know we have a huge ukrainian
population in canada just today 25 000
people showed up in downtown to support
so
thank you for what you're doing and i
really appreciate your time thank you so
much
you